معظم الناس لا
يحبون الحقيقة
[الموسيقى]
نحن نعيش في
جيل مرتبك من حيث صلته بالحقيقة ،
تتمتع الكلمات
بالقوة والحقيقة تهدف
إلى بناء
دونالد جي ترامب يقول
أو يغرد على أي شيء يشعر به مثل
قوله أو  عندما تغرد
إلى تدميره ،
عليك أن تسمعني اليوم
لمجرد أنك تقول ما يدور في ذهنك
وما تشعر به
لا يعني أنك وكيل جيد
على الحقيقة
[موسيقى]
عندما تكون من مكان
ما تفتخر به  لذلك ، بالنسبة لي ، كنت دائمًا ما كنت أستخدم
المنتجات ضدهم في مكان
ما كان صعبًا كما يمكنك الذهاب
من حرم
جامعة بين والمدينة الجامعية في شارع 40 ،
ثم يمكنك إجراء منعطف واحد
وأنت في الأسفل تريد أن
تجعله 50 في  مشروع
كونك في الغرب فيلي الآن
مثلما تعرف هذه الكتل الصغيرة
مثل هذه المنازل الصغيرة الصفية التي ترى
أشخاصًا يعيشون فوق بعضهم البعض ،
أضمن لك أينما كنت في
روسيا أينما كنت
لا أعرف حتى على الأرجح
ما هو منزل الصف الذي يطلق عليه اسم منازل الصف
[الموسيقى]
في أي مكان في هذه المدينة وهذا الحضري في
أي منطقة حضرية إذا كان لديك حدث أو
شيء من هذا القبيل لديك أشخاص
يخرجون بنوايا حسنة ،
نعم لديك دائمًا أشخاص قد لا يفعلون ذلك
لديك نوايا حسنة أنك تعيش
في
فقر شديد لدرجة أنك تعرف أن لديك
رجالًا في الحي اليهودي
ورجالًا في غطاء محرك السيارة لديهم
أشياء لطيفة وأشياء مادية
ثم لديك ما يسمى
بالذئاب والذئاب خرجت وأنت تعلم
أن هذا  يشكل خطرًا على من أنت
سواء كنت رجلًا عاملاً سواء
كان تاجر مخدرات لذا يبدو الأمر كما تعلم
الآن ، الجو بارد الآن لذا
سترى أشخاصًا يرتدون أشياء مثل كل
هذه القبعة السوداء التي حصلت عليها
جميعًا  - قناع أسود ،
فأنا الآن موسيقي وأنا
ممثل وأنا ناشط ، لذلك لا
أريد أي مشكلة ولكن
شخصًا آخر يمشي معك تعرف
أنه ما هو
[موسيقى]
إذاً
[موسيقى
] أنت الآن في شرق بالتيمور
وهذا هو مول البلدة القديمة
s هو مركز تجاري يجب أن يكون مشهورًا جدًا ،
هذا هو المكان الذي مثل الكثير من
الأشخاص السود مثلي
عندما كنت طفلاً نأتي ونشتري ملابسنا
[موسيقى]
لديك متاجر لبيع الخمور ، لديك
صيدليات
لديك متاجر لمستلزمات التجميل لذا
كان هذا مثل  متجر شامل
مثلك يأتي إلى هنا ويفعل كل شيء ، لقد
كان مجتمعًا متناميًا خلال
السبعينيات والثمانينيات
، وهذا هو مركز الفندق
الذي حدث هنا مثل أي
مجتمع آخر
خلال السبعينيات والثمانينيات كان حجمًا كبيرًا
من
المخدرات وكما يمكنك  ترى هذه النغمة أصبحت
بيئة تهريب مخدرات الكثير من
المخدرات ومع ذلك يقال أن بعض
المتاجر وبعض المباني
قد تدهورت للتو بسبب
تهريب المخدرات
وأه مع ذلك القليل من
العنف يتم إطلاق النار على الناس.
سرًا
لأنها أدوية مختلفة ،
حبوب منع الحمل ، حبوب منع الحمل تحظى بشعبية كبيرة
هذه الأيام.
مع
إحضار ابنها
إلى هنا ليأخذه للحصول على شيء
يأكله ،
وبمرور الوقت ، تدهورت الأمور نوعًا
ما ،
ذهبت إلى شارع لانكستر على بعد ميلين من
هذا الطريق ،
فأنت في أحد أجمل
الأحياء في بنسلفانيا
جدة حيث يمكن  كن بريان من
منطقة المدرسة العظيمة والمنطقة الدنيا من ماريون ،
لكنك تذهب إلى كتلتين بهذه الطريقة ، تريد المركز
52 ولانكاستر حيث
قُتل رجل قبل يومين فقط في
محطة الوقود أصيب برصاصة 16 مرة في
محطة الوقود ،
تذهب  هناك لخفض ماريون بعد
برامج المدرسة ،
ومعامل الكمبيوتر ، تبدو أشياء فريق كرة القدم
كما لو كانت في الاتحاد الوطني لكرة القدم ،
لقد حصلوا على كل ما لديهم من
كل شيء ، لكن
كان عليه أن يذهب بعيدًا لمحاولة
ممارسة الرياضة ، وحتى لو كان يعرف ذلك
لقد حصلت على أم عازبة باهظة الثمن ،
وهي بالكاد تستطيع إطعام هؤلاء الأطفال ، لذا
فأنت تتحدث الآن عن 300
للاشتراك في كرة القدم ، فقد تقول
إنك لا تلعب أي مشكلة ،
فأنت تتحدث عن
فرق ميلين وميلين  الفرق في
الشباب هو 13
14 12 9 وهذا ليس ميلين فهذا
فرق مليوني ميل
لأنه إذا نظرتم جميعًا إلى هذه المنازل
هنا انظروا إليها تبدو
وكأنها تبدو مهجورة فهناك
أشخاص يعيشون فيها  انظروا بشكل صحيح إلى هذا المكان ،
إنهم ينظرون إلى بندر ، هناك
شخص ما في منطقة أخف في الطابق الثاني
مما يعني أن شخصًا ما يعيش
هنا في الطابق الأول قد لا يتم
تنظيمه حتى لا يعيش أي
شخص ويعيش شخص ما في الطابق الثاني ،
نعم الناس الذين يعيشون هنا في
بعض الأحيان لا  حتى
أنه لا يمكنني الذهاب لمسافة ميلين بهذه الطريقة بشكل صحيح ، فبعض الناس
لا يعرفون حتى الشكل الذي يبدو عليه الماريون السفلي ،
تخيل طفلًا ينام
ليلاً لا يحصل على حرارة
مناسبة ، ومن الرائع أن هذه
حقيقة واقعة هنا  هذا ليس
مجرد شيء نرغب عنه ونتحدث
عنه الآن ، فأنت لا تزال في شرق
بالتيمور ، هذا عبارة عن
مشاريع إسكان للثياب يعيش الجميع بالقرب من
بعضهم
البعض بحيث يعرف الجميع بعضهم
البعض  هنا
كما ترون ، إنه حي
قاسٍ من شرطة المخدرات وحشية ارتفاع معدل الجريمة
والنظام الغذائي ما نأكله لقد فسد ،
ليس لدينا طعام جيد هنا
لتناول الطعام ، لديك
متاجر بقالة حيث تشتري العائلات
وجبات
خفيفة مثل الوجبات عالية الفقر
منخفضة  معدل التعليم يرتفع أثناء الحمل ،
هناك الكثير من جرائم القتل التي تحدث
هنا ، فقد الكثير من أصدقائي
حياتهم في هذا الحي
لا يستطيع الناس الحصول على وظيفة يبيعونها للمخدرات
هنا أنت تعلم انتظر الناس ليأتوا
بوم بوم بوم بوم بوم
كما تعلم  وبهذه الطريقة يكسبون المال
لا يمكن السيطرة عليه ، عليك البقاء على قيد الحياة ،
يبدو أنها غابة ،
لذا في الغابة عليك أن تتصرف مثل
أسد من بين الأسود الأخرى
عليك أن تتصرف مثل الوحش بين
الوحوش الأخرى ، لذلك هذا هو
البقاء للأصلح في
يمكن أن تتوسع عقول الناس
إذا كانوا قريبين من بعضهم البعض ، وهم
محبطون ولا يعرفون كيف
يعبرون عن أنفسهم ،
مما أدى إلى العنف الذي صممته الحكومة.
إن مشاريعهم
تجعل الناس
مكبوتين
[موسيقى]
أعتقد أن البيئة التي
نشأت فيها تلعب دورًا كبيرًا فيما يتعلق
بما تختبره في حياتك
وكذلك ما ستصبح عليه عندما تكبر في
كثير من الأحيان في بيتسبرغ يموت الناس  في
مواقع محددة ،
يستخدمون الزهور ودمى الدببة
لإنشاء نصب تذكاري في الحال ،
لذا آمل أن يكون تذكيرًا
لمواصلة تعزيز
سبب عدم السير في الطريق السلبي أو
الطريق المظلم
في حياتي البالغة.
عن طريق العنف المسلح
في homewood ،
كان أحدهم يعمل نادلًا في
حانة محلية وجاء راعٍ
وقرر إطلاق النار عليه
داخل الحانة ، امرأة شابة أخرى تُدعى
janiece tolton قُتلت
في حانة أعلى الشارع من
ymca لأنها لم تفعل  أرغب في
إعطاء رقم هاتفها لرجل
كان هناك
، ثم هناك صديق آخر من
أصدقائي يُدعى
فريدريك دوغلاس قُتل في شارع فرانكستاون مباشرةً ، لست متأكدًا من
سبب ذلك.  بالضبط ولكن
كل هذه الأماكن تقع على بعد دقيقتين
من ymca وهو أمر فريد لأن
هذا هو المكان الذي يذهب إليه الكثير من أطفالنا
.
تعد كرة السلة [الموسيقى] لعبة سهلة للأطفال لالتقاط
واحدة لأن كل ما تحتاجه هو كرة سلة
يمكنك أن تضيع فيها  اللعبة لساعات
أو سنوات أو حتى مدى الحياة بالنسبة لبعض
الأشخاص مثل مايكل جوردان أو كوبي
براينت تصبح دافعًا
والأهم من ذلك أنها تمنحهم فرصة
للهروب
[تصفيق]
[تصفيق
] الكثير من الأطفال يتطلعون إلى الرياضيين
والفنانين  لذلك يريدون حتى أن يكونوا
مغني راب أو ليبرون جيمس القادم
أو يريدون أن يكونوا ذلك
العصابات في الحي تاجر مخدرات في الحي وهو أمر
رائع أيضًا
حتى يحصل الأطفال على فرصة لرؤية
في بيئتهم ولديهم
خيارات مثل بيع
الكراك روك
أو  لقد حصلت على قفزة شريرة من
أجل الهروب من غطاء محرك السيارة ،
ما الذي يحدث في كرة السلة ،
حسنًا ، ما الذي خططت له اليوم
ما هي بعض الأشياء السيئة التي
ترى
الناس يطلقون النار على الرجال كيف  منكم جميعًا
رأوا شخصًا ما يُطلق عليه الرصاص قبل أن
يرفع يدك ، وهذا ما قاله أحدهم ،
دعني أخبرك بما لا يمكنك أن تكون
حول الأشخاص السيئين ،
أوه ، كانت الأسباب بسبب وجود
انقسام
كما تعلمون والمبدأ الكامن وراء
القسمة لهذا السبب أتذكر
أننا  بالنسبة للولايات المتحدة الأمريكية غير
المقسمة ، كانت
هذه المنطقة بأكملها سوداء ، لذا ما
حدث هو
أنهم وضعوا هذا الطريق السريع لم يهتموا
بوضع الطريق السريع
أسفل منتصف اليمين مباشرة وسط
هذا المجتمع الداخلي الأكثر ازدهارًا في المدينة والذي
يُطلق عليه جناح جاكسون
والذي في الواقع  كان اسمه أسود وول
ستريت ، كان هذا مزدهرًا ، ثم
قسموه هنا
، وبينما ننتقل إلى هذا القسم ،
سترى أن
الإسكان الحكومي الانتقالي أصبح مخدرات عالية الجريمة
كل شيء بالإضافة إلى
الطريق السريع
كما ذكرت بعضًا من
تركت الشركات المملوكة للسود أعمالها
لتذهب إلى مناطق أخرى في هذه المنطقة
هنا ،
ثم أصبحت الحي اليهودي ، وهي واحدة من
مناطق الجريمة المرتفعة في
الوقت الحالي  نظرًا لأننا نرى الاختلاف
هنا ،
انظر ، نرى أنه لا توجد
طوابع طعام للرعاية الاجتماعية للشركات الحكومية ، فإنك تحصل على مدمن
مخدرات ،
وبالكاد تتعايش وتعيش بعيدًا
عن الحكومة ،
ترى أن أداء السود أفضل عندما لم نحصل على
المساعدة
عندما  لم نحصل على المساعدة ، لقد أدينا
أداءً أفضل لأننا اضطررنا إلى
فعل ذلك لأنفسنا
حيث تبدأ في تقديم المساعدة للناس
ودفعها لهم ، فهذا ما يحدث أن
هؤلاء الأشخاص معتادون على التحقق
الذي يكفيهم فقط للعيش  في
هذا النوع من الظروف ،
يريد أن يفتح مشروعًا تجاريًا في
منطقة عالية الجريمة
لأنه بعد ذلك تتعرض للسرقة ،
هناك عدد قليل من
الفرص هنا في غرب
بنسلفانيا
وكذلك لم
تتحرك صناعاتنا فحسب ، بل انتقل الكثير من موظفينا
بالإضافة إلى ذلك ، الأمر الذي أجبر
المزيد من الشركات على الانتقال ،
من الصعب للغاية إدارة نشاط تجاري
في مكان مثل homewood
لمجرد أنه لا يوجد الكثير من الأشخاص هناك
ومن ثم
لا يوجد شخصان هناك  ssary يعني
الاستفادة من الأشياء الإضافية ،
إحدى الشركات الفريدة
التي تمكنت من أن
تكون مكانًا ثابتًا للبحث عنه والمنزل
مع أعتقد أنك تعرف أنه لا يقل عن
50 عامًا
وأن السيد بوندي كان هناك كما تعلم
أه صنع تلك الكعك للأطفال
للتأكد من حصولهم على الطعام قبل
ذهابهم إلى المدرسة
لأجيال وأجيال ، لذا حتى
في تلك المواقف التي إذا
لم يستطع أبي وأمي الاعتناء بها ، كان
الأطفال يعرفون أنه يمكنهم الذهاب إلى
المخبز
وأخذ قطعة دونات أو احصل على شيء ما
للتأكد من حصولهم على بعض الطعام من
أجل قضاء يومهم ،
لذلك لا أعرف كيف فعلوا ذلك ، لكنهم
وجدوا طريقة
ليكونوا حاضرين دائمًا في هذا
الحي على الرغم من ما مضى
جميع الأحياء جيدة أو سيئة ، كما
تعلمون ، ليس لدي أي شكاوى من
homewood هنا على الرغم من
أن الحي قد تغير فقط ، فأنت
تعلم أن بعض الشركات قد غادرت منطقتها ،
ولا أرى أي أعمال جديدة قادمة في
الوقت الحالي.
مترو الأنفاق في مدينة نيويورك لم يستوفوا حصتهم
هنا
بغض النظر عن ما تطلبه الشركة من أجلك ، تعلم
أنهم ذهبوا
لأنك تعلم خمس سنوات وست سنوات ، نعم ، هذه هي
المدة التي قضوها خارج هنا ،
لقد أغلقوا للتو ، تعلمون
أن هذا مجرد  الجزء الصعب
وحول البنادق والقتل التي تحدث في
شارع فرانكستاون هو واحد من أكثر الطرق ازدحامًا
في غرب بنسلفانيا ، إنه أحد
أطول الطرق وأكثرها استقامة ، لذلك
يركب الناس من
الأحياء الثرية
خارج بنسلفانيا الغربية
ويركبون عبر خشب المنزل من خلال  حركة المرور
كل يوم للذهاب إلى العمل وهو أمر
مجنون إذا ذهبت إلى الأخبار ، فستقول أنك
تعلم أن شخصًا ما قد قُتل في المنزل ،
لذا فهو ليس مكانًا تريد
إيقافه والتوقف وربما تناول قطعة
دونات في القهوة بدلاً من  اجلس في
زحمة السير
[موسيقى]
يا رجل
ما حصلنا عليه هنا هو أكثر
أعمال عنف تعرفها أكثر من رائعة تم الاحتفاظ بها
مع جريمة القتل
بالتيمور ميريلاند ولكن في بعض الأيام حصلت على
شيء رائع جدًا من الداخل
إلى الخارج  إذا شعرت بي ،
فتحدث عن طعامك وكيف
أثر ذلك على التكلفة ، بدأت كيف
بدأت بستين دولارًا ، بدأت بستين دولارًا ،
بدأت بستين
دولارًا ، لا يوجد غاز لا ماء ساخن أو
لا يوجد شيء
يبيع الطعام في منزلي فقط لكسب
لقمة العيش
الآن كان ذلك آمنًا ، كان الأمر نفسه في
نفس الوقت الذي كان علينا أن نسير فيه بإيمان ، كنت
غاضبًا ،
لذلك عندما أحول غضبي إليك ، كان الأمر
ماليًا ،
وضع غضبي في صخبتي لمجرد التواجد
في المجتمع ، يجب أن تفكر في الأمر
بمجرد أن
تمسك بالرأس ما تحاول أن
تدمن مدمنًا ، فعندما تتحول إلى
مدمن ، كل ما عليك فعله هو مثل
التحكم ، يجب عليك تغيير العادة إلى
سلوك جديد ولكن مدينتنا كما تعلم
هي ما اعتدنا الخروج منه  من
الجزء الذي سنقوم ببيعه للمخدرات ، هذا هو
ما في بيئتنا ،
يجب علينا أن نتسلق
طريقك للخروج من دلو السلطعون الذي تعلم أننا نعرفه
بالنسبة
لسرطان البحر ، فنحن في القاع يجب
أن نتسلق الطريق
بغض النظر عن الكيفية  عمرك بغض النظر عمن
أنت  عليك أن تصنع اسمًا
لنفسك ،
معدل الجريمة لدينا الآن هو
رجل رأس مال مرتفع جدًا مقارنة
بمناطق حرب في الواقع يقولون إن
المزيد من الأشخاص يتعرضون لإطلاق النار في بالتيمور ،
ثم يتقدمون في السن في المملكة العربية السعودية في
مكان ما ،
إنه نوع من الجنون ، نعم  الحديث الحقيقي عن
الأشخاص الذين يبيعون ممتلكاتهم رجل ،
الناس يتعبون ، الأشخاص المتقاعدون ،
المزيد من الجرائم تزداد كلما زاد خوف الناس في
سنتي الأخيرة ، اكتشفت أنني كنت أنجب
طفلاً من امرأة لن
أتزوجها ، لذا
تركت المدرسة  بدأ العيش
خارج منزل والديّ
في الانغماس في بعض الأشياء التي
لم أكن بحاجة إلى الانخراط فيها
ووضع نفسي في موقف يكاد
يُقتل في عام 2011.
ونتيجة لهذه التجربة ،
اتخذت قرارًا بالبدء في القيام بذلك
ما أفعله
مع فريق كرة
السلة وأبدأ في التركيز أكثر على مسيرتي الكروية.
العب مع زملائك في الفريق والأهم من
ذلك التنافس ضد الفريق الآخر
وكذلك البيئة عندما
يفكر الناس في كرة السلة لا ينظرون
إليها في هذا الجانب حيث تقوم بتقسيمها
لأنها معركة شخصية
إنها معركة بين فريقك و  الأشخاص الآخرون ،
إنها معركة بينك وبين
البيئة ،
إنها لعبة مهارة ، إنها لعبة
عدوانية
وجسدية حيث تضطر إلى
المراوغة ،
فأنت مجبر على القيام بالكثير من الأشياء التي يعتبرها
الناس أمرًا مفروغًا منه  في الحركات اليومية ،
كان هذا الشغف الذي
تمكنت من الحفاظ عليه منذ طفولتي والانتقال
إلى مرحلة البلوغ هو ما سمح لي
بأن أكون مختلفًا تمامًا
عن أي شخص آخر وخلق
فرصة حيث قال الناس إنه يمكننا أن
أتمنى ذلك
العمل للعثور على أطفال آخرين في
أحياء الأمثال في المقام الأول في
homewood حيث بدأت
رصاصة بيتسبرغ لتعليمهم كيفية تسخير تلك
الطاقة والحفاظ على هذه الطاقة
في adu
بعد ذلك ، يمكنهم الاستمرار كما قلت للقيام
ببعض الأشياء التي قمت بها
إذا لم آمل أن نأخذها إلى أبعد من ذلك وأبعد من ذلك.
ونفقد الكثير من الأشخاص كل
يوم كل يوم ، فأنا أذهب إلى الإنستغرام ،
نعم ، من حسن الحظ ،
هناك شخص ما
وهذا طفل آخر يتيم
، وهو امرأة أخرى
لم يعد الرجل إلى المنزل ، إنها
أم لقد سئمت  من رؤية
الأمهات السود يضطررن إلى دفن ابنهن الأسود بشكل
صحيح وهذا فقط وهذا أمر واضح تمامًا
كما يمكنني أن أصفه ، لا أريد أن أرى
أشخاصًا يُقتلون في
ممفيس حيث تذهب رماديًا ، لا أريد
أن أرى الناس يتعرضون  قُتل في روسيا
اللعنة ، أريد أن أرى أشخاصًا
يُقتلون في فيلادلفيا ،
يعتمد معدل الجريمة لدينا على استخدامنا للمخدرات ،
فأنت تعلم أن الأشخاص لا يُقتلون
بسبب أي شيء
95 من الجرائم أو 85 بالمائة على الأقل
من
الجرائم تتعلق بالمخدرات ،
كما تعلمون  نحن أم  في الوقت
الحالي ، نحن الآن
عاصمة القتل الأولى في الولايات المتحدة ،
نحن أيضًا
رقم واحد في إدمان الهيروين هنا
لماذا لأن لدينا الميناء الذي يقع في
الأسفل
هنا ونحن على حافة الساحل الشرقي
لذلك الكثير من الأشياء  تعال عبر
الموانئ
وأشياء الطريقة التي يتورط بها الأطفال في تعاطي المخدرات وهم
يكبرون في المدينة الداخلية بمجرد أن تخرج
من باب منزلك ،
فأنت هناك حقًا قد
يسألك شخص ما عندما تخطو خارج بابك ،
عفواً ،
هل تعرف أين  يمكنني الحصول على بعض الأعشاب الضارة
من عذرًا جيدًا ، فأنت تعلم الحصول على بعض
المنشطات
جيدًا ، عفواً ، أنت تعلم حصلت على بعض فحم الكوك
حسنًا ، عفواً ،
أنت تعلم أن بعض حبوب منع الحمل في
الوقت الحالي يمر المجتمع
بتغيير ،
وهناك تغيير يحدث في هذا
المجتمع لأن
جون هوكينز في قيمة العقارات
آخذ في الارتفاع ، لذا لن يبقى الكثير من هؤلاء
السكان هنا
لفترة أطول من اللازم وسيحضرون
الطعام الجيد لأنه بالفعل جنوبًا
بكل شيء يدور حول التباعد  الآن
كل شيء حتى تحصل على ما
يرام لديك أشخاص أثرياء يعيشون
بجوار الفقراء ،
لذلك في نهاية المطاف لن يكون الفقراء
موجودين
بعد الآن ، حيث يقومون بنقل
الفقراء إلى المقاطعة بهذه الطريقة ،
لذا فإن أصحاب المنازل يعطونهم
قسائمهم وقسائمهم مما يعني أنه يمنحك حق الوصول إلى
منزل آخر
ولا يتعين عليك دفع أي أموال ، فقط
انتقل إلى الداخل مباشرةً ،
ولكن قد تكون على بعد
ساعة من المدينة ،
لذا أصبحت المدينة الآن وباء متناميًا
تمامًا مثل الثروة ، فإن
الصراع لا
يشمل الأشخاص
الموجودين بالفعل
وهذا هو الصراع ، والصراع
لا يشمل
الجميع ، كل شخص مقيم في الوقت الحالي
لم يتم
تضمينه في أي خطط مستقبلية ، وهذا هو
الصراع
الذي يتغير لأن دونالد ترامب
فعل ذلك.
يرسل لك دونالد ترامب سلة
مليئة بالأطعمة الملوثة لقد وصلت بالفعل
إلى
الإنترنت والناس لا يحبونها ، لذا فقد
تدخل دونالد ترامب حقًا واشترى الكثير من
الناس  من لديه حقًا
حرية الاختيار ، ليس لديك
حرية اختيار ما تأكله الآن ،
فأنت تأكل مع الحكومة
تمنحك عدم استخدام بطاقتك والذهاب لإخراج الطعام
من السوق الآن ،
نعم إذا كنت تريد  الرفاهية
التي ستحصل عليها من سلة دونالد ترامب
التي أرسلها لك مثل
سلة مليئة بالطعام ،
الحكومة الحكومية ، نعم ، لذلك لا يمكنك أن
تتغيّر الأشياء ويريد الأثرياء
الوصول إلى
المدينة ومع ذلك يأتي
الزنجبيل  العطلة يتم الكشف عن الكثير من الأشياء في
الوقت الحالي ،
فأنت تعلم
أن الكثير من الناس يذهبون إلى الكنيسة
وأنت تعلم أنهم يقدمون القرابين وأنت
تعلم أنني لا
أتحدث بشكل سيء عن أي دين أو
أتحدث فقط من
ملاحظتي ولكن في  في نفس الوقت
عندما يكونون في
حاجة إلى نفس الأشخاص الذين اعتمدوا عليهم
روحانيًا ،
لا يمكن أبدًا أن يكونوا موجودين من أجلهم ماليًا
، ولا تضيف
[موسيقى] أبدًا ،
فأنت ستضغط على
يدك وتتأكد  إصبعك يبقى بعيدا عن
آر  قم بتدوير المسدس إلى هذا الموضع
ثم تأكد من ضبط يدك بشكل
صحيح ورفع المسدس وإبقائه في مستوى العين على
ما
يرام حتى يكون كل من الجزء العلوي والجزء
العلوي على نفس المستوى ، حسناً ، نسيت ما
رأيت فيه  الأفلام على ما يرام إذا قمت
بالتصوير بالطريقة التي تصورها في الأفلام ،
فلن تصطدم بأي شيء أبدًا